welcome to Rio de Janeiro's Jeanette
Sarina the newest home 2017 mid season
the invitation you'll kill me sit on the
other side I have to get the parents are
you kidding me no the double kill the
guy is not alive are you kidding me
honey we're going to ask with the
waitress the results to lock it down is
the best team in the world and SKT are
once again the champion there already
oh my god it's a party in the bottom
Lane chain of corruption slowly sergeant
spread shock wave underwater kickback
double double double kill g2 and look at
the health bars on g2 that was clean
will expand on emotions on the ice ice
giving us jumped up and the 3d ones got
GA I don't think he's going to be able
to survive this with no support from the
rest but what about Baron right now
because W they're running straight for
de Icaza is near the Baron trying to
make maybe biggest deal ever four five
seven competitors to survive from their
second four cups before me coming down
the draft by four seven one bad one
like magic at the Baron are you kidding
me people for a long time we buy the
degree v where's the chalk gonna go a
little bit one-sided Journal called
title he survives a few seconds longer
but TSN lose to wild turtle had slashed
and he was still corn bash qss both
available and he ends up going down
it can't happen forgive them
compositions that the ad carry dies
first
alright we rejoin the action and spin
scare is looking for Archie the chain of
corruption is going to start after
[ __ ] in my wild endles gun for this
because up just fine long enough to get
two more kills but the against the
approximate people give a pyro fun
you'll find it with aspirin now Levi's
trying to find wild turtle vegan sausage
in my 1000 HP on the beragon against us
tonight but he's gonna that's Barrett in
40s Evans doing theme for this year's
win though hard seas B is going to be
killed up but not for depicting life
I've done an hourly fly just little way
with the delivers his own escape path
with the carry us team with most people
had powering second that is pretty
brutal hunters probably have to rank his
eat here unless he already skilled up
straight on to haunt as 200 HP anymore
heads gonna have to look through the hop
and
he was taken they get the engaged pots
are done that BP and partha they can
take down hot services for sure I think
going to be a bear awesome over the wall
a 2v1 now V Erickson they're low on mana
bus you'll be able to dance around this
one with hauntzer cards hook down
there's a shutdown what's needed for the
team perks can try something as is all
deep on the waters and then it's on
display should be able to bounce back
around he is going to take one but
that's a one-for-one here come to me
damn it boy oh no the double kill the
guard it's not alive are you kidding me
bro this will get TSM TSM not going to
go ahead until right now - like Oh guys
we find this review rush back there's an
answer there but they're going to force
this no trick should probably not go for
a steal and not give away the kill but
middle inhibitor turret is dead the
inhibitor is gone as well I'm going to
get a fight here at the five feet rear
where they lose their face first g2 are
still pushing for the Nexus to the
bottom left corner of your screen
they're still looking for the base and
TSM has to get back there it's been
offended before they're going to lose
the game is he gave it up live officers
trying to start the packet
the kids the next to the lime connect
our first NGS loved to arrive to give a
try here we go they tell them now here
comes hunter does he have the damaging
preventive effect my photos the flash
pit box out one Jill pardon here comes
they're gonna stop them connects is
going to fall is here Sam I have cash
take the win over G - Ricky Connie he
mostly comes down strangle forms is
coming up Jackie nitrogen-14 up Simon up
back to the right come on protect keep
Singaporeans on a perfect game is ruined
Casa said you've got fisted the trick
space now cost is running away with his
life expects the hall this is the toxic
is pasta sliced it booty he being in you
know another side looking at throat
ASEAN flashes in for this one feels
apparent and now the fight from skd to w
e9 v 7 looking to separated but he's
already use the ultimate and Daisy now
flip the team business expects of the
goals lead sisters cue robberies proving
it peanut with a disengage ultimate
follows in with the sonic wave for the
resonating strike the record is broken
now Rudy overheating with a flames pizza
he's looking again another defensive
flash sure our sleep doing it the gig of
every season observe Luther's are about
to a 50 G they're gonna tell
Thank You Jamie we had it playing
whack-a-mole with the Marine okay screw
it peanuts already broken the 3:15
killed not the most killed in a game in
a game at MSI what's it like here it was
18 Mira is getting close to that there D
NATO can't fix a clocked him down two
and a half our cheese now the target for
his four teams kill you know lighted up
there's the first to know but for
something you need to do this / - get
them wait it out very patient here
Ottoman could be decided under adventure
luminous as well
versus lies so much wrong about what
can't them did breakdown that in there
really does go back going way too far
forward you may just go down here that's
one of those dudes he's I didn't wanted
to hit hook that's going to be Optimus
going down to the other side of the
fight though arching in a bad spot Dodge
is the end of the line it's a plateau
now Dean well be Redemption and they
look for a different fight expect on the
front line also gets least a Redemption
from myth he's been holding off his
damage quite a while tricking spent now
deciding what they want to do but now
the powerbreathe are together there's a
doc go for first
this is a turnaround they were looking
for dark in the eyes of g2 and they're
going to wipe the team out with bearing
parties are you going F just had Megan
burn Obama's going to drop burns a huge
amount of damage but they he could be
next but and inspect that Missy now
expected they have overstayed their
welcome in gigabyte sane he takes a
better me their goal to stop business
and then yeah Yahoo last quarter fizz
happen
yep you actually had about another half
second on the fish to walk closer to the
wall Baker did not want to miss that
flash a very rare mistake
what he's trying to do a steal he's
going to seed that is not to be and
that's going to slow down here come back
alive again quick king of ivory if you
skill a nice kill too early yet wud that
will buy sometimes three for the actual
triple kill for Becky's also a quadratic
allow for versus five of big students
they need to make these happen inside
Lee so go play all put that thought I'm
going to route him down
so up to the everybody disappear kill
boxes of the ah place both in the [ __ ]
mahir's maple tell us what get the
change-up going left damage second trail
as a flash will come alive Melinda
campaigner now going to be the one
rooted on flask over maple women not a
long-range chase this goes over a little
cover [ __ ] is the insulin Apostle Peter
dead and its Casey in one fell swoop may
we'll end this game maple volleyball
stop dead to her knee to knee nugget
Wofford us to administer rested upon
Betty it's they're killing this hangs in
the frontline and SK Cedars will not be
stopped photo trucked out into oblivion
and that's going to be Game one SK
Telecom a bit of time he gets quoted by
MMD zeven going to come out there
that's get in by the big creeper hassle
honey leaving way increase the waifus
the results do moving through nipple
buddy helping in the consulars of eating
wave Rudy on a embarrassing tivity
meetings in hurry he's going to try and
execute all shut down barely priming up
their first one well I just keep
fighting her bang a look in another to
be doing don't sit down been getting
chocolate knees get a little further
forward back taking a little too much
seven cause of us have a fatty oh my god
Nick something talking in the heel is up
scrap get down a penny not gonna get a
bag will straight into they will sweep
the platform there will be friend their
appetite championship and they will do
what they have always been is going to
get locked up the foul it's almost
backpack which they think is going to
keep shooting up famous black and may
you get the sexy expect kill twisting
the sm57 looks for the jousting into the
bedrock look at the heroic entrance
expects a fist refuse taking longer zero
nine five seven running for their life
for the Antichrist looking for targets
missing it's not something to be another
black
[Music]
such a good play Brooke drinkies
expected looking for the Saudi kids
missing maybe have the game here in the
desk should comes down
do you feel like you've been redeemed is
this enough redemption for you
personally uh well me personally maybe
but I would like to take at least a game
of SKT deploy in the bank or exhaustion
sake classic Jake and now make it oh the
PP&E there's really no way out his land
Kingdom Baker Kenny dawn we're in the
mid lane RunAs hair and paper
what's the barrier good against us back
saying live a quick second rocker and it
doesn't matter
three-oh preferred they just shot him
and that's repeated against the wall
easy kick into gear there's going to be
the kill picked off the first one in for
SKT to be defined expect though actually
once the changement tanks come down
hoody it not flats in time in the Midway
Gilbert versus whether the taste is on
and trick might be dropped but as well
the poet there should be a quick few
bills since then
stop any of it as Baker watchable us one
double kill quickly gravina
down amid the other rocks out of this
one mobsters heal both matter peanut
flash the tape to get that one picked up
the block and will not go out of the SKT
match that fight open and a great
knockin as well the follow sir is in
look at the damage they picked up waters
inspected and SP continue to exert the
damage shout but mrs going to be next up
soon first will get a trade kill for one
but recording up husband then can't get
much down either first enough to make a
little bit of edges on this floor but
when he's still on the chase peanut as
well against comes in circle for the SKT
jugular vein will be spelled man is next
up with a chopping block he can't get
away from this one Baker
hoping to make the kill happen he will
make a go share this coming take it back
and they bring Baker with them they've
got the frontline of kite to fight let's
see what they can kill whooping sounds
bigger pulls it away is the lives of
borrows he use the - away - men knocking
trick as well bag on the wings oh here
comes the shield what kill to kill make
is limited for playing expect was back
and he gets a pass double cover the
gameplay now the taste on oh Rudy can he
pick up off revenge for leaving the
European MC end he's running away to
stay alive one more shot to mobile to it
and that's the filter
the eggs going to be a been in the
European LC ssgt report peptide of the
series
one akkad isn't going to be an absolute
law term if you've got no way out SKT
wiping the floor with g2 and burgers up
next to blast you to follow the
shockwave apply and apply three quick
and easy to the delays and just like
that strict on half HP is bigger once in
the following world we know the only
prevents the kid from doing anything
he's got falls down Mindy wants to Train
buy something for it no damage of a
baker the plasters not at all there's a
submissive son of a baker that should be
enough for the killer first Gibson does
not Auto fall damage any more than
enough tears birthday man he gets the
picked up now from anybody not gonna
trade his life for maybe peanut should
play go let's prevent a chemical that
maybe is located in a video to encourage
you to stay alive oh it is getting
cloudy boys SKT diving service here hey
Dee do come on
rashad came in just in time to lock it
down as the best team in the world and
SKT are once again the champion
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button